facebook's audit director and marketing
leads are former pfizer directors well
what do you say
what do you say
color me shocked
okay
facebook a platform that routinely
censors posts critical of covet 19
vaccines has hired several alumni from
pfizer's marketing and internal audit
teams to lead similar efforts at the
social media platform the national pulse
can reveal
the hires appear to present a conflict
of interest you don't say
you don't say
for the social media platform which has
come under fire for censoring and
banning users who've posted about the
side effects or question the efficacy of
coven 19 vaccines now who are these
people you ask well let's look
facebook's internal audit director for
example was formerly a senior director
advisor
the employee tiffany stokes has held the
influential position at facebook since
january 2020. oh that timing that's
interesting
prior to joining facebook stokes worked
at covet 19 vaccine maker pfizer for
five years
as the senior director of its finance
and legal operations
interesting the national pulse can also
reveal that a facebook vice president
for global clients and categories was
formerly pfizer's chief marketing
officer for consumer healthcare in the
u.s that employee brian groves worked at
pfizer for a total of 14 years not a
short time
before joining facebook as a director of
its global accounts and similarly it
goes on
a former director for digital marketing
and innovation at pfizer joined facebook
as a client partner for its global
marketing solutions branch in 2018. in
addition goes on and on you should read
the article just read the article
it's called facebook's audit director
and marketing leads our former advisor
directors it's at the national pulse
it's worth a read now
hmm i thought about this for a second i
got a little twisted i'm not gonna lie
because i knew a lot of people
who went and got the vaccine in good
faith they made that decision with their
doctors or with themselves decided and
had a bad reaction it happens people
have bad reactions to all kinds of
pharma drugs it's not exclusive to the
vaccines the difference with the
vaccines is the liability protection
that's the difference because it comes
under the emergency use authorization we
talked about that yesterday
but they had a bad reaction whatever it
was some mild some severe
i have friends that i have one friend
that got myocarditis had to be on blood
thinners all types of medication i had a
friend that had a stroke
we have a family member that got very
sick has some neurological problems that
they've been battling these things
happen it's a drug company all of a
sudden we can't call out a drug company
and say hey just a question what's going
on these people simply went on facebook
and said hey they were scared
they were looking for some type of
community some type of information you
know why because they went to their
doctor and they got a lot of i don't
know it's a new i don't know i don't i
don't think it could be linked
i don't know i haven't seen this before
no you haven't seen it before because
it's a new experimental vaccine and we
don't know right so these people were
just looking for community they were
like can somebody help me can you do you
know anyone who's had this i'm going to
the doctor i'm not getting answers i
don't know what to do they were lost
they were scared they were confused
that's what people do right think about
yourself as a human being you get
confused something's going on with your
health we all know that if your health
is jeopardized nothing else matters
right you can't think you can't focus
you're just worried you get on the
internet you start looking we all have
this chip
maybe not my dad my dad's like oh i'm on
fire it'll cool down
seriously tony you got a gift that's all
i'm gonna say
but most people go on the internet they
look and they try to find information
so people were using utilizing facebook
for that there were also people who had
questions about the vaccine when it came
out who were questioning the mandates
who were calling out the fact that it
wasn't designed to prevent transmission
they were coming in with facts
i can't tell you how many people got
silenced censored d-platformed for just
asking questions and just pointing out
realities scientists were on there
doctors were on there people on there
who was saying i can't
i can't authorize this for this patient
i can doctors will come in and say i can
authorize it for these but not this one
why are you telling me i have to they
were uncomfortable
well they spoke too much censored gotta
get him off so a lot of this was going
on a lot of people saw this going on and
they were like what what what what's
happening here and now we find out
that facebook
facebook and pfizer have a little bit of
a of a relationship going on they're
more than friends let's say it that way
they're more than friends you know when
you were like going out with somebody
you're like well we're not boyfriend
we're more than friends that's what's
going on here more than friends
okay so
i think people are awake now in many
ways there's a lot of collusion that's
gone on and it's prevented people from
getting accurate information a it's
prevented people from being able to
speak their minds be it's prevented
people who have suffered at the hands of
a big pharma drug or whatever from just
feeling like they can talk they can ask
questions a lot of this is just asking
questions remember i'm not a doctor
i'm not a scientist i'm not your doctor
but i'm a person living in the world
seeing what i see and asking questions
when did that become a bad thing well it
became a bad thing because thinking
people
are a problem
for the misinformation police the
misinformation police
always
so
i think you need to be aware
and on high alert to to what's going on
with this collusion with silicon valley
you got facebook you got twitter you got
big pharma you got oftentimes
big government machines democrat
establishment machines are locked in
there
you got the cdc we saw the cdc and the
teachers unions working together on
talking points about school openings
those decisions weren't being made for
your kids health they were political
decisions we know that now the proof is
in the emails that were disclosed about
the collusion
you want to learn a little bit then
people say well the fda watch dope sick
watch dopesick
watch it
there is a revolving door
between
people who work for the fda
people who work for big pharma people
who work for the cdc people who work for
big pharma very often times that
compromises the ability of these people
to do an honest job
i remember scott gottlieb going on tv
he's a big pharma guy
he's on the pfizer board he would be
going on cable news
talking about the vaccine giving advice
about the vaccine i you know at the time
i had cable i don't have cable anymore
thank heavens
but i had it at the time and i would see
and i'd be like
why aren't they disclosing that he he
works he's on pfizer board
maybe that's a conflict of interest just
in terms of the type of advice you may
be putting out there
well
he was on networks that were getting a
ton of money from big pharma do you see
what's going on here
there has never been a more important
time for you to become your own citizen
journalist you need to do your research
when it comes to your health
your family
your body
do your own research gather it you have
a team of trusted doctors that have been
through you know good times and bad
times with you talk to them
if you can't ask them a question
think about that relationship think
about what's going on there if you like
the short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]
you